Hello. It's Chocolate Week.
Ooh, I love chocolate.
Are you a chocolate man, Noel?
No, I'm an actual man.
Welcome…
[both] To The Great British Baking Show.
-[Noel] For the remaining bakers…
-[Laura] Don't drop…
[Noel] …Chocolate Week has arrived…
-[Lottie] Melting in my hands.
-[Noel] …with a back-to-basics signature.
Brownies are a very basic thing to bake.
If you can't get that right…
-[Marc] Getting hammered.
-Ruthless.
[Matt] A return to bread
in the technical…
What have we got to prove? Everything.
Maybe if you stroke it,
it'll get a bit bigger.
-Might do.
-[Matt] …and a showstopper…
[Dave] The thermometer's saying
it's 25 degrees,
not ideal for white chocolate.
[Matt] …that gets them
all hot under the collar.
Don't forget, you only have to be…
-not the worst.
-[Lottie laughs]
-What a great mantra.
-[Prue chuckles]
Just don't be the worst.
[opening theme music playing]
[rain pattering]
Chocolate Week. [laughs]
Yeah, it's fun.
Absolute fun, this one.
[Laura] Massive chocoholic.
[chuckles] A day without chocolate
is a day wasted.
Chocolate releases endorphins
but that tent does not always
release endorphins.
I think it is quite a stressful place,
so maybe if I have some
chocolate halfway through my bake,
I'll feel a bit better. [laughs]
Hello, bakers, welcome to the tent.
It is Chocolate Week and it's time
for your signature challenge.
Okay, their names are Paul and Prue.
-I know.
-You say that,
-but you always get 'em wrong.
-No, I don't.
-All right. Paul and Prue.
-I know.
Prawl and Poo would like you each to make
a batch of 18 chocolate brownies.
You may use
any type of chocolate you like.
You can use as many additional flavours
as you like.
But we will be looking
for that nice, fudgy texture,
and when I say we, I mean…
Bloral and Ploo.
-You have one hour and 30 minutes.
-On your marks.
-Get set.
-Bake.
[Noel] Brownies
may be famously simple to make…
Put anything in a brownie that you like.
Long as you don't overcook it
and keep the middle nice and gooey.
[Noel] …but the bakers have
just 90 minutes
to produce the perfect batch.
[Lottie] It's the timing
I'm worried about.
We're all up against it.
To get them cooked, cooled and ready
in an hour and a half is gonna be tough.
The perfect chocolate brownie
has a gooey centre,
and it has a crackly, crisp top.
And that's it.
The bake on the brownie
is the critical thing.
If you overbake it, it will become
very, very dry and cake-like.
[Prue] Although the bakers
can decorate their brownies,
all icings are very sweet
and extra chocolate is more sweetness.
So I think they should try
not to over-decorate the top.
This, for me, is going back to basics.
If you can't produce
a decent chocolate brownie…
there's gonna be problems.
-Hello.
-Good morning.
Tell us all about your brownies.
-These are my Christmas brownies.
-[Paul] Yeah.
Er, they remind me of when I was a kid,
and we used to have all the nuts
and Turkish delight and dates
that were a real treat.
[Noel] Linda's treats of Christmas past
will be studded into a layer
of white chocolate
on top of her date-filled brownie.
-What texture are we looking for?
-Nice and gooey.
-[Paul] Gooey.
-Good luck.
-Thank you.
-Good luck. I might just stay here.
-Thank you. Okay.
And wait till they're ready
and then eat them.
-Keep stirring.
-Want me to--
If you're gonna… Yeah. Be useful.
[Linda laughs]
[Marc] So I'm making
a rich chocolate brownie
with roasted macadamia.
I hadn't made brownies
till a few years ago.
I wouldn't say they're my favourite cake.
[Matt] Perfecting the recipe
for his praline buttercream brownies
has given Marc sleepless nights.
-I'm tired. Really tired.
-Are you? I'm quite tired.
I woke up in the night.
I was sleepwalking and driving--
As a vampire,
that's what you're meant to do.
-I call it sleepwalking.
-Sleepwalking.
-Other people call it…
-[laughs] Being a vampire.
Taking people into the bushes
and sucking all their blood out.
I mean, people like to split hairs.
[Matt] The bakers' quest
for the perfect gooey centre
starts with their brownie mix.
I think it's all about the ratios
in your recipe,
so how much fat you've got,
erm, how much flour you've got.
If you add too much flour,
you're gonna start getting a cake.
[Noel] So getting
their calculations right…
-Little bit too much sugar.
-[Noel] …is crucial.
-I like your purple calculator.
-It's good, innit?
Haven't seen a calculator for a while
because I've got a calculator app
on my phone.
We're not allowed our phones in here.
-Are you not?
-No.
Because you'd be ringing going,
"Mum, can you come and get me,
I don't like it here?
They make me bake all day.
And then I bake all day,
a horrible man with a beard comes along
and says, 'It isn't good.'"
[Noel] But this bake
should be child's play for Dave,
as it's inspired
by his favourite childhood sweets
which will sit on top
of his rich, ganache-topped brownies.
They better taste mine last.
They won't be able to eat any more
after mine.
[Noel] Hoping for
a slightly healthier brownie…
-[Peter] These are some good-looking figs.
-[Noel] …is Peter.
Peter, that looks amazing.
So I'm making fig and pistachio
upside-down brownies.
So I've got a layer of figs underneath
and that's gonna be flipped out
and become the top.
And I've got some cinnamon going
into the brownie batter.
It just tastes really good
alongside the chocolate.
It's very untraditional.
-[Prue] It's certainly unusual.
-It's risky.
[Matt] Peter's hoping
for a riot of texture and flavour
with his unusual fig-topped brownies.
-What did Paul say when you said figs?
-Erm.
Did he go, "Ooh"
or did he just stare through you
with his cold, blue eyes?
When I said most things, he just did that.
[Noel] You must've made brownies.
Everyone has.
Surely. Have you made brownies?
I've made brownies. [mouthing]
I haven't made brownies.
No, I… I've never baked. [chuckles]
-You never bake, like, ever? Never ever?
-Never.
-Baking's for losers.
-[laughs] This is good inside knowledge.
I make brownies all the time at home.
My husband really likes brownies.
But it's, you know,
Paul Hollywood and Prue Leith
who are judging it, not my husband.
He'll eat anything.
[Matt] Her husband might not be fussy
but Sura is hoping
to win over the judges today
with her ruby and dark chocolate
marbled brownies.
[Sura] It could be great.
Or it could be… We'll see what kind
of a disaster this turns out to be.
[Laura] So I'm going in.
170 for 20 minutes.
[Noel] Getting their brownies
baked and cooled
as quickly as possible is crucial,
if the bakers are to leave themselves
enough time to cut and decorate.
That goes in at 180 for about 25 minutes.
[Noel] But Lottie is going to have
to run the oven gauntlet twice.
[Lottie] They're going in
for 25 minutes to start with
and then another 25 minutes
once they've got the toppings on.
[Matt] Lottie's ambitious
double-baked brownie
will have a chocolate and pecan base
and a baked raspberry cheesecake topping.
[Lottie] I've given myself
a hellish pile of work to do.
I think I can get it done.
Obviously, what will suffer
is my decoration
but as long as it tastes all right,
I'm happy.
-Hermine, good morning.
-Hello. Morning.
Hermine, tell us about your brownies.
So I'm making raspberry,
-white chocolate and pistachio…
-Wow.
…brownie.
How long are you going to cook them for?
Ten minutes on one side, get it out
then ten on the other side.
-20 minutes.
-On the other side?
-Turn around.
-Oh, the tray.
Yes, the tray.
Problem is, when you do that,
you drop the oven's temperature.
-But isn't that good thing for brownie?
-Is it?
[Noel] Hermine has also added coffee
to elevate the chocolate flavour
of her brownie,
which she's hoping
she can bake to perfection.
If the baker says
you're not supposed to turn it round,
maybe I'm not supposed to turn it around.
-So we're not turning it around.
-[Matt] Bakers, you are halfway through.
That was nice.
-Forty-five minutes.
-Now I'm gonna make my Italian meringue.
-[Matt] The bakers' choice of topping…
-Gonna blitz the hazelnuts.
[Matt] …should enhance
the flavour of their brownies…
On the top, there's gonna be
tiny little cubed Turkish delights
and chopped nuts.
[Matt] …without adding too much sweetness.
[Dave] On top, there's gonna be
a milk-chocolate ganache with honeycomb.
They are a bit sweet.
[Lottie] This is my cheesecake layer.
This goes back in the oven for 25 minutes,
or as long as I can spare.
So I am making
the Italian meringue buttercream.
There's a few Italian meringues
in the tent today.
[Sura] It's like sweet overload
but so worth it.
[Mark] It's like Donald Trump's hair.
That's how you know your meringue is done.
A Trump on your whisk.
[chuckles]
[Noel] Mark's Italian meringue-topped
brownies will sit on a cookie base
in his take on
his favourite camping treat.
A s'more is usually something you have
with marshmallows and biscuits
over by a campfire,
so I thought I'd, er,
convert that into, erm… into a brownie.
[Matt] Also hoping to score brownie points
with her s'mores-inspired bake is Laura.
S'mores is quite an American term,
but it basically means
like melted marshmallow, I think.
I'm doing a posh version
with Italian meringue.
[Noel] Laura's Italian meringue
will be piped
on top of her decadent chocolate
and hazelnut brownies
before being drizzled with
a rich salted caramel sauce.
I'm hoping the salt and the caramel
will cut through that
and then you get that nice balance.
[Lottie] So, these are going back in
for another 25 minutes.
[Matt] With Lottie just halfway
through her bake time…
[Lottie] I'm praying to the brownie gods.
-[groans]
-…the others…
[Hermine] Brownie, cook. Brownie, cook.
[Matt] …now face a game of nerves…
It's never failed me
to leave them in for 33 minutes.
It still stays all nice and fudgy.
[Matt] …as they must judge when
their brownies are perfectly underbaked.
[Mark] Ooh.
No, they still need a bit longer.
Oh, come on.
[Noel] Get them out too soon
and they could fall apart.
Looks good, we've got a nice crack on top.
[Noel] Leave them in too long…
Just gonna get
a couple of minutes, that's all.
[Noel] …and they risk
losing the fudgy centre.
[Hermine] They're still a bit… Oh, gosh.
Gotta give it another five minutes.
That's not good.
[timer beeping]
[Sura] They're completely raw.
Gotta get these in the freezer.
Just need it to cool quickly.
I'm gonna take mine out now.
I'm gonna get it out, I think,
'cause I really don't wanna overdo it.
I do really wanna a nice, stodgy middle.
That looks good to me.
Let's hope they cool in time.
[Peter] Into the fridge.
We've not got long.
[Sura] Still a bit raw in the middle.
The thicker they are, the longer they take
to cook so… my fault, really.
[groans]
Yours in the oven?
[Lottie] Yeah. Another 15 minutes
before they can come out.
It's not gonna be pretty, the end of this.
Bakers, you have
insert-number-of-minutes-here
minutes remaining.
[chuckles]
[Noel] You've actually got
half an hour left.
[inhales sharply]
It's not enough time.
-What you doing?
-I'm still baking.
-Still in the oven?
-Yeah.
-What?
-Hmm.
If you need any more time,
I do do the time call
-so I could cheat for us, okay?
-[laughs]
You're my favourite,
don't tell the others.
I'm just gonna take them out.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes remaining.
Yeah, what you gonna do about it?
Probably carry on baking
and try your hardest.
That's very hot.
I'm gonna defrost the freezer.
[Laura] Don't drop,
don't drop, don't drop.
[Marc] Ideally, I'd leave them
longer before cutting,
but time's of the essence.
When it hasn't gone right in practice,
it's just, pfft, splurge out the side.
[Matt] Only now will the bakers find out
if they have judged
their bake times correctly.
Oh, thank God for that. [chuckles]
That is perfect inside.
Very happy with that bake.
[Laura] They're a bit raw.
Unfortunately, Paul's gonna say probably
now that they're not quite right.
Let's see how raw it is,
shall we, on a scale of
-one to raw?
-Think it's still raw?
-[Lottie] I'm fairly confident it's raw.
-Got time to put it in the freezer?
-I did and the freezer melted on it…
-Oh.
…because it was so hot and now,
this is all wet freezer juice
that dripped onto it.
-"Wet freezer juice"?
-[Lottie] Yeah.
"So, what's your topping again, Lottie"?
"It's wet freezer juice
and then also I dipped it in bin juice
-'cause I wasn't pleased."
-For good measure.
So tuck in, Blue Eyes,
see how that grabs you.
[both chuckle]
[gasps] Ugh!
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
-[blows raspberry]
-[Noel] You can do this, bakers.
Oh, the stress.
Oh, the stress is too much.
Just piping on the Italian meringue.
I think these are looking pretty darn
rootin'-tootin' good. [chuckles]
[Marc] Mine are a mess.
[Lottie] Just gonna pop
some of this over there.
They look a treat.
[Linda] Yummy, yummy, yummy.
[Sura] So, I'm just thinking if I can
split one tin into 18 brownies.
Oh, what a hot mess.
No, not gonna try.
[Mark] I'm happy with that.
[chuckles] God, to the wire.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please put your bakes
at the end of your bench.
It's horrific. Mine are raw.
Not cooked, look at 'em.
[sighs] Well, at least they're gooey.
It looks like an actual car crash.
[Matt] The nine batches
of chocolate brownies
now face the scrutiny of Paul and Prue.
-Hello, Peter.
-Hi, Peter.
[Paul] They look attractive on the top.
[Prue] They really look lovely.
It's got the chewiness,
but it's coming from the dates,
-isn't it?
-Mmm.
-What spices did you put in there?
-Cinnamon.
I think there's too much cinnamon
because the cinnamon
has overtaken the chocolate.
It's different. It's risky.
It's okay.
-[inhales]
-[Noel] That is brutal.
-Thank you.
-[Peter] Thank you.
[softly] It's okay.
It's a bit disappointing.
Oh, dear God, here we go.
Good luck, honey. You'll be great.
Hmm, it looks as if they came out
of the oven too early.
[Paul] Yeah, it does look a mess.
Let's have a look, shall we?
-[Prue] That's too much Italian meringue.
-Okay.
It's too sweet.
Really?
-[Paul] Far too sweet.
-Okay.
'Cause you've got caramel,
you've got the meringue on the top,
you've got the chocolate.
You go, "Enough now."
-It's underbaked.
-[Laura] Mmm.
[Prue] A few problems here.
-We need to get them out of there.
-[Sura] Yeah. I had two trays of brownies
and one of them actually fell inside
the oven, so I've just presented one.
-[Prue] Very tough.
-[Sura] Hmm.
[Paul] I don't like the flavours.
I do. What is it?
Dark chocolate and, er, ruby chocolate.
'Cause I'm getting a sort of citrusy kick,
but that must be the ruby chocolate.
-[Sura] Yeah.
-[Paul] Hmm.
[Prue] But the bake's not right,
and obviously, you haven't got enough.
-[chuckles]
-[Sura] Yeah.
-[Paul] Not your best work.
-No.
[Marc] We're getting hammered.
Ruthless.
Okay, well, they look, er, neat.
And they look pretty identical.
So, I've got a cookie base
with a dark-chocolate brownie
with Italian meringue
and some sugared cranberries.
[Prue] It tastes like a brownie.
I'm slightly avoiding the top
because I know that'll be very sweet,
but overall, I think
it's a really good job.
Thank you.
The biscuit base is too thick.
I like your flavour.
I just think your textures were wrong.
Okay. Thank you.
[Paul] They're a bit messy.
I like the raspberry acidity,
but the white chocolate is just too much.
[Paul] A lot going on in there.
You've got coffee, chocolate,
raspberry, pista…
[Prue] You've got a lot of sugar.
[Paul] It's sponge-like
rather than brownie-like.
See? Looks like a chocolate sponge.
I like the flavour.
It's unusual, it's nice.
It came down to the bake itself.
-Okay, thank you.
-[Paul] Thank you.
[Paul] They're all pretty even.
Yeah.
It's overbaked. It's more like
a sponge than a brownie.
-Tastes great. I like the flavour.
-Yeah.
It lacks the two things
that I think make a brownie,
that is the gooey middle
-and the crackly top.
-[Dave] Yeah.
-You made a good traybake.
-Thank you. [chuckles]
-They don't look good.
-No.
I was running out of time basically,
so it was a rush at the end there,
so I apologise for that.
-[Prue] It's quite dry.
-Okay.
If you go right to the middle,
it's nice and squidgy.
I think the flavours are okay.
-It does look a mess.
-[Marc] I know, I'm ashamed of it.
That's a problem. Brownies
are one of the most basic things to bake.
If you can't get that right…
What they gonna say to me,
if that's what they're saying to Marc?
-I'm gonna get roasted.
-[chuckles]
-[Prue] They don't look great.
-[Paul] They look a right mess.
-Like they've been dropped.
-Yeah.
[Noel chuckles]
[Lottie chuckling]
Have you got a straw?
Not on me. Would you like a spoon?
[Prue] Hmm.
I love the, erm,
sharpness of the raspberries.
But there is too much cheesecake mixture.
Sort of overpowers it.
The flavour's okay.
-Textures are all wrong. Looks terrible.
-[Lottie] Yeah.
-Besides that, brilliant.
-Nailed it.
-[Prue chuckles]
-Thanks, guys.
If any of us had just presented
a standard chocolate brownie, I think
we'd be away, but none of us have.
We made it harder than it needed to be.
[sighing] Oh, God.
We've all done
a botched job of our brownies.
That was brutal. I mean, brownies.
What are people
watching this gonna think of us?
We're meant to be the best
amateur bakers in the country
and cannot make brownies
to please Paul and Prue.
[Matt] The bakers
could practise their brownies,
but their next challenge,
shrouded in gingham,
is a complete mystery.
[Noel] Hello, bakers.
Welcome back to the tent.
It's time for your technical challenge.
Today, it's been set for you by Paul.
Paul, any words of advice?
The brownie challenge was easy.
This isn't.
Concentrate on your textures.
As ever, this technical challenge
will be judged blind,
so we're gonna have to ask
these two to leave the tent and…
have their eyes temporarily removed
by Belgian robots.
-Have they gone?
-Not yet.
Can you go?
[Noel chuckling]
Prue's lurking about the entrance.
Okay. Judge Paul Hollywood
-would like you each to make…
-[Noel chuckles]
…a chocolate babka,
which is a traditional Jewish loaf cake.
Your babka must consist
of an enriched dough
with layers of nuts and chocolate,
and it needs to be rolled,
split and then twisted
to create the shape.
[Matt] Once baked,
it should be brushed with syrup to finish.
You have two and a half hours.
On your marks…
Get set…
Bake.
Babka, here we come.
[Dave] Never heard of one.
If brownies are simple,
then we've got no chance, none of us have.
[Linda] Don't know what it is,
never made it.
I wish I knew what it looked like.
So, Paul, why have you chosen this babka?
[Paul] Basically, it's an enriched dough
with a chocolate filling.
You roll it out into a rectangle,
roll it up as if you were
making a Chelsea bun.
-Hmm.
-Cut that in half,
and it's a case of spiral twist.
It's a plait, basically,
but you can't make it too long.
If you make it too long,
it won't fit in the tin.
Not easy.
Rather typical of Paul Hollywood.
[Paul] Shall we have a look inside?
[grunts softly] And there it is.
Crisp on the outside
and then that beautiful soft inside
with this gorgeous chocolate
mixture with the hazelnuts in it.
Lovely. Much lighter
than I thought it'd be.
-Hmm.
-I've had it in New York,
and it's not nearly as nice as this.
I had it in Birkenhead. [chuckles]
I'm reading these instructions today
to make sure I'm not messing anything up.
"Make the dough." Nothing else.
No further instruction.
Thanks, Paul.
I haven't made enriched dough that often
so I'll just have to wing it.
Enriched dough,
it's got butter and milk in it,
and you mix it up with the eggs,
whereas a general dough,
I mean, it's just flour, yeast and water.
-[whirring]
-That's the sound
of enriched dough slopping about.
[Hermine] You should be able to stretch it
without the dough splitting,
and you'll know that it's ready.
I'm happy with the dough,
it's really nice and stretchy.
Mate, this dough is too wet.
There's no window pane coming out of that.
The dough's really nice.
It's quite sticky.
"Roll out the dough into a rectangle
measuring 40 by 30 centimetres."
[Sura] Thirty'd be, like, out there.
[Lottie] Here we are again,
trying to make rectangles out of circles.
"Spread the chocolate mixture
over the dough,
leaving a one-centimetre
border around the edges."
I'm just trying to go
for a nice even layer… ish.
You're just doing that
in such a liberal, sort of, free way.
-[Mark] Do you think?
-You're quite free.
How free are you?
-How free are any of us?
-No, well, exactly.
What's the free-est thing
you've ever done?
-Erm…
-You ever got naked in a public space?
[chuckling] I haven't, no.
-Wanna do it now?
-We could.
-[Noel] We could streak in the tent.
-[chuckles]
[Dave] "Scatter
the hazelnuts over the top."
-"Roll the dough into a tight roll."
-[blows raspberry]
-[Lottie] Lol.
-It's all about the shaping in the babka.
Trying to remember exactly what it
looks like in terms of the twists in it.
Crucial moment.
[Mark] "Cut through the middle of the
dough into two long pieces."
"Then lift
the right half over the left half…
followed by
the left half over the right half,
repeating the process
to make a two-stranded plait."
-That guy over that guy.
-[Linda] Yeah.
-Then that one over there.
-[Noel] Then seal.
[Lottie chuckling] That can't be right.
That looks ridiculous.
What now?
"Carefully lift into the tin."
Absolute jokers.
Mine is a bit too long.
This is not 40 centimetres.
Gonna go like this.
This is all extra, it's too long.
I'm loving your work.
Oh, yeah!
Come on, high five.
There you go.
From there…
Let me see, "Prove until
doubled in size." Okay.
What have you got to prove?
Everything. Everything to Paul Hollywood.
[Lottie gasps] Well, that can't be right.
Why doesn't mine fit?
Maybe it'll, like, lift in the middle
or something and take shape.
Don't really know
how long I need to prove it for.
Half an hour, let's check it.
I'm gonna set a timer for ten minutes.
[Laura] Let's just get it in.
I don't know what you're supposed
to do, but can you be good to me?
Yeah, okay, I'll let them know.
Bakers, you're halfway through.
-Through.
-Yeah. They know now.
There's a lot of
waiting around on proving things.
Slightly unnerving.
[Hermine] To rise or not to rise.
-[Linda] That is the question.
-Yes.
[baker sighing]
[singing]
♪ Carefully lift the loaf into the tin ♪
Mine wasn't carefully lifted.
♪ Prove until it becomes double in size ♪
Good luck with that.
♪ Bake, make the syrup
Brush the babka with the syrup ♪
[both chuckling]
That seems fairly straightforward.
It's got a little bit bigger.
-Got a bit bigger.
-Yes. Not as big as I would like.
Maybe if you stroke it, it'll get bigger.
Yeah, it might do. [laughs]
-Generally works. [laughs]
-[clears throat]
I think mine is ready to go in the oven.
[Dave] I wouldn't say it's doubled.
It's like one and a halved.
With the time that's left,
it's gonna be passable,
shall we say. I'm hoping.
[Lottie] Right,
so it's not doubled in size.
That's the shape that mine's
gonna be, and that's the end of it.
Off we go.
Just trying to work out
how long it's gonna take to bake it.
-So, I'm just gonna do 25 minutes for now.
-[timer beeps]
[Lottie] Oh, I don't know about that.
Maybe I should tuck the ends under?
It's all in the bake.
[Mark] It's the waiting that's the worst.
Just waiting. Waiting and hoping.
-How's it going?
-It's brown on the ends
'cause I left them out and they were
clearly supposed to be tucked in.
Can you cut the ends off?
-Anything you can do?
-I was tempted.
But then he'll see
that I've then carved it.
-You should say to him, if he goes on…
-Yeah.
[mimics Paul] "It's burnt at the end."
-"It's a bit burnt at the end."
-"You know, it's a bit overbaked."
-Yeah.
If he does that,
go, "I've never seen one before."
-"I didn't even know what one was."
-Yeah, just like that.
-Yeah.
"Don't put it on me. It's on you."
-I'm gonna try that.
-You should do that.
Yeah. Winner, winner.
-[Matt] Follow my advice.
-[chuckles] I shall.
Bakers, you have five minutes left.
[Linda] Coming out.
Ready… steady…
babka!
[Peter] We got ourselves a babka.
[Mark] I'm happy.
Got a nice little zigzag design.
[Linda] I quite like it, actually.
Yes, it doesn't look too bad at all.
[Lottie] No rise on that.
Really not convinced that that's cooked.
Look at all that messy
chocolate stuff all down the side.
Oh, well.
[Marc] Gonna spread some syrup.
[Hermine] A bit of syrup to glaze it.
Seamless.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please bring your chocolate babkas
to the front of the tent
and place them behind your photographs.
Mine looks like a Viking longboat.
Oh, my God, the embarrassment.
[Noel] Paul and Prue are looking
for a beautifully-risen babka
with a gorgeous
chocolate spiral all the way through.
Crispy on the outside
and soft on the inside.
[Paul] Right.
Now looking at this, it looks good.
It's small, but you can see
the lines all the way through.
-[Prue] Yeah.
-[Paul] Let's have a look inside.
[Paul grunts]
[Prue] The swirl's good.
Mmm.
Even though it hasn't
risen as much, it's very tender.
[Paul] Hmm. It's got a nice bake on it,
and the combination
of the chocolate to the dough is good.
Moving on to number two. Few issues.
[Prue] Sunk in the middle.
Not the best looking
babka I've seen. [chuckles]
-[Prue] It's not overbaked.
-[Paul] No.
The flavour's okay.
It's the way it's twisted and
the way the chocolate's been put
that's created that drop in the middle.
Moving on. This is a nice one.
[Prue] This looks like a model babka.
Colour's good. Stripes are good.
Nice bake all the way round,
good height, as well.
[Prue] Shine's good.
So all it has to do now is taste good.
-Mmm. Excellent.
-Good flavour.
Now this one,
big issues with
the plaiting side of things,
so it's very, very small.
-[Prue] Looks bit heavy, too.
-[Paul] Yeah.
-[Prue] Yeah.
-[Paul] Feels much tighter.
-Bit heavy.
-[Paul] Hmm.
Okay, moving on.
[Prue] It does
look like a babka, doesn't it?
[Paul] It does.
It is amazing, isn't it,
how much chocolate
you can get into the dough?
[Paul] Hmm, it's got a very cakey
-feel to it.
-Lovely.
[Paul] Moving on. Big gaps in this.
[Prue] It doesn't look so attractive.
No, it doesn't.
Needed more proving.
-It's very dense, this.
-[Prue] Hmm.
Yeah. It's odd.
[Paul] Moving on. The size isn't bad.
A few holes in there, but actually,
it's quite a nice size loaf.
-[Prue] Bit dry.
-[Paul] Hmm.
Now, moving on.
Neat, but again the plait's
not entirely way through.
-It's one and the other side.
-[Prue] Yeah.
Wow, it's heavy. It's really underproved.
Tastes good, though.
[Prue] Mmm. Funnily enough,
this has got very few plaits,
and yet the height is there.
[Paul] And you can see there,
it's fairly open.
It could do with being a little bit more.
Tastes delicious.
[Matt] Prue and Paul will now
rank the babkas from worst to best.
Okay, in ninth spot, we have this one.
You struggled a bit
with shaping it into the tin.
It seems to be really high.
And then in eighth place,
we have this one.
Dave, didn't get much rise on it.
So it was a little bit heavy.
[Noel] Sura is seventh, Marc is sixth,
Hermine, fifth, Peter is fourth.
In third, we have this one.
Very neat, just could've done
with being a little bit higher.
Right. Now number two…
is this one.
Laura, the only thing wrong with this
was that it sank
a little bit in the middle.
But it is a really nice babka.
Thank you.
So, in first…
we have this one.
[all clapping]
-Have you made one before?
-No.
Very, very good.
I think you did a good job on that.
The swirl was good,
the height, couldn't fault it.
Well done.
I know.
I know. I'm so…
[laughing] I'm so shocked, myself.
I just followed my instincts,
and there you go.
[Laura] That's the first time
that I've had good praise
and come second, and it's
a confidence boost I really needed.
[Sura] That was horrific.
And that was two challenges…
pretty much failed.
So tomorrow, I have to
pull it out of the bag and hope that
the weather is on our side.
It's gonna be hard.
[Matt] Just one challenge remains
before the first Star Baker is crowned,
and one baker will be asked…
-Oh, God.
-[Matt] …to leave the tent.
Hello, bakers, welcome back to the tent.
It's time for your showstopper challenge.
Today, the judges would love you to make
a spectacular
white-chocolate celebration cake.
Now, your cake should be made
with a particular celebration in mind.
For instance, it could be the first time
you went to the toilet by yourself.
-[laughing]
-For Paul, that was last Thursday.
Well done, we're all proud.
[laughing]
Well done, Paul, there's your gold star.
-[baker chuckles]
-No more nappy.
[all laugh]
You get three of those,
you get a book token, little man.
Hmm. Your cake should
have a minimum of two layers,
and the decoration needs to
display an expert use of white chocolate.
[Noel] You have four hours.
-On your marks…
-Get set…
-Buh…
-Ah…
-Kuh…
-Eh.
[Peter] White chocolate's a crowd pleaser,
so hopefully it's gonna be
a good, yummy bake the judges like.
[Mark] I love white chocolate,
which is why it's dangerous
to have these jars around.
[Lottie] I'm blitzing it because
it does incorporate a bit better.
Also, I don't know
what I'm doing with this one,
so, it's a gamble.
The showstopper challenge
is to make a white-chocolate tiered cake.
One of the big challenges for the bakers
is introducing the white chocolate
into the sponge.
White chocolate has a higher fat content,
which means, if they
got butter in the sponge as well,
they need to reduce that,
so they're not really
upping the fat content in the sponge,
which would disrupt
the texture of the cake itself.
I think it's a really tricky challenge
'cause white chocolate
is, frankly, a nightmare to work with.
It splits at the drop of a hat,
it seizes if you get it too hot.
[chuckling] And I think
the bakers will have their work cut out.
With the weather being so warm today,
the bakers are gonna
have to be extremely careful
how they introduce
the white tempered chocolate
or ganaches on the outside.
They're gonna have to compensate
with the fact that they may start to melt.
Hopefully the ambient
temperature in here doesn't go above 20,
otherwise we're all in…
in for a bit of a worry.
I'm not a massive fan
of white chocolate because, erm,
although I have a sweet tooth,
it's very sweet
and it's very one note, white chocolate.
Erm, but I think, in a cake,
you can celebrate it with other things,
which is what I'm gonna do today.
[Noel] Laura's white-chocolate sponges
will be sandwiched
with Italian-meringue buttercream
and a sharp blackcurrant jam.
And for a touch of romance,
she'll be decorating
with a chocolate bouquet
to celebrate
her two-year wedding anniversary.
It was your anniversary yesterday.
-Yeah.
-How exciting.
-What did you do to celebrate?
[both chuckling]
-I was here.
-You were here.
Making brownies
and getting rinsed by Paul Hollywood.
Getting told off
by a grumpy man with a beard.
-Yeah, basically.
-Yeah.
-Great way to spend your anniversary.
-You think?
[Noel] Romance is also
in the air for Lottie.
It is a celebration cake
for my grandparents,
they are celebrating
their sapphire wedding anniversary
-in January.
-Wow.
-What is sapphire? 65 years.
-Sixty-five years.
-That's incredible.
-Yeah.
[Matt] Lottie's ambitious design
will feature a sapphire-geode effect
and an array
of tempered-white-chocolate decorations.
[Prue] Have you practised this?
I have practised this cake
between 15 and 18 times.
[Prue] Oh, Lottie!
This is a really tricky one for me.
Don't forget, you only have to be…
not the worst.
-[laughs]
-What a great mantra that is.
[Paul and Lottie] Just don't be the worst.
-Well, good luck.
-Thank you very much.
That spurs you on, doesn't it?
[Matt] Making a tiered cake
requires perfect light sponges.
If you're trying to stack it,
you need it to be light,
otherwise it will collapse on itself.
[Matt] So it's crucial
the bakers get the ratio
of white chocolate to butter spot on.
Because white chocolate
has such a high cocoa butter content,
I've used a bit less butter
than I would normally.
Too much white chocolate will sink.
So I'm using a small amount
that I'll incorporate very gently in.
[Sura] It's very temperamental.
It's like, the worst chocolate
to work with.
-[Paul] Good morning.
-Good morning.
-[Prue] Hello, Sura.
-How are you feeling?
-Yesterday wasn't your best day.
-No, it wasn't. It was horrific.
Today, I'm optimistic
and hoping for the best.
[Noel laughs] From horrific to optimistic.
[Matt] Celebrating her parents'
36th wedding anniversary,
Sura's elaborately decorated cake
will feature tempered-chocolate ruffles
and piped buttercream flowers
that will encase layers
of strawberry and lemon jam
and white-chocolate sponges.
How are you getting the chocolate
into your cake?
[Sura] I watered it down,
so it's gonna make it a looser texture,
but also still gonna have the flavour
without the heaviness of white chocolate.
-[Paul and Prue] Good luck.
-Thank you.
-Good luck.
[Sura] Thank you.
[Matt] While Sura's banking
on diluted white chocolate,
Peter's going for
an altogether different texture.
[Peter] Adding chunks of white chocolate.
I like it when you come across
that hunk of white chocolate
in a bit of cake.
That's what I'm doing in this one.
[Noel] Peter's chocolate-studded sponges
will be sandwiched with a mango curd
and whipped cream
and surrounded with a chocolate collar
painted with complex equations.
It's the celebration
of his brother Andrew's recent graduation
from a degree in mathematics.
He graduated this year.
But he hasn't had a full ceremony
-because of Covid.
-Yeah.
So I'm celebrating that through this cake.
Celebrate it in the tent
where he can't eat it and we can.
I've practised one at home
and he's enjoyed it.
[Paul] Right, okay.
[Noel] Hermine is building her cake
from genoise sponges,
where whisked eggs and the flour
are traditionally combined
with melted butter.
I'm replacing the butter with,
er, the white chocolate here.
That reminds me of the wedding cakes
at my parents' wedding.
Not that I was there,
'cause I was still really young.
But, erm, I've seen pictures of it.
[Matt] Her throwback wedding cake
will be decorated
with a white-chocolate collar
and piped ganache roses.
Inside, she will layer
her delicate sponges
with lemon curd
and Italian-meringue buttercream.
Well, I love genoise.
-I think it's beautiful.
-I do.
Nice combination of flavours as well,
with the lemon.
-Thank you. [chuckles]
-Thank you very much.
So, if Paul Hollywood
is not complimentary,
are you gonna take one of the cakes
and smush it into his face?
Say, "Well, now see how you like it."
-Will you do that?
-Could you?
-I would.
-You'll get away with it.
-I wouldn't.
-You would.
You'd be a national treasure
for doing that.
[Noel] But Marc is hoping to keep
all three tiers of his cake intact.
Dedicated to his daughters,
Rosie and Jasmine,
it will be decorated
with their namesake flowers
and sandwiched with
raspberry Swiss meringue buttercream.
I'm nervous because
the comments weren't
particularly good yesterday
and I know cakes aren't
my particularly strong point,
so, yeah, I kind of,
in my, in my perspective,
I'm feeling I'm close to the bottom.
[Noel] There's also a lot
riding on this bake for Linda.
[Linda] This means a lot to me, this cake.
It's a tribute to my daughter, actually.
Melissa had special needs.
She's no longer with us.
You know, she passed away when she was 18.
But this is just a celebration
of her life, really.
And she was just
a sweet little English rose.
[Matt] Linda will craft a chocolate rose
to sit atop an all-white
three-tiered sponge,
filled with amaretto raspberry jam
and mascarpone cream.
-You had a triumph yesterday.
-I did, didn't I?
-I enjoyed it.
-[Noel] You're enjoying yourself.
In actual fact,
the directions were really brilliant.
-Thank you.
-[Noel] Don't give him credit.
-No, they were good.
-Thanks.
-Have you got one of my books?
-I have.
-I think you'll do really well.
-[all laughing]
Okay, here we go.
Attempt number one.
Please, please bake.
[Noel] With their sponges in the ovens…
I'm gonna check it
after about 26 minutes, to be precise.
[Noel] …the bakers now
turn their attention to the fillings…
God, I love multitasking.
[Noel] …which means more white chocolate.
It'll be white chocolate overload,
but that's what they asked for.
What they do on this show is
tell you to make really sweet cakes
and then they tell you off.
Yeah, Prue will just go,
[mimics Prue] "It's too sweet."
[laughs]
"It's a little sweet."
You go, "Yeah, 'cause you told us
to make a cake full of white chocolate."
[mimics Prue] "I just thought,
to balance out the sweetness,
-you could've put some mud in there."
-[laughs]
[Noel] Luckily, Mark's wife, Laura,
is a big fan of this cake
as it's in honour of her birthday.
Covered in tempered-chocolate shards
and geometric shapes,
the interior is full
of her favourite flavours,
white chocolate, pistachio, lemon
and a South African
marula fruit cream liqueur.
This is Laura's favourite drink,
and elephants get drunk on this.
Elephants eat fermented marula fruit
and, er, get drunk.
Yeah. So I quite like it, yeah.
Thought I'd throw it in here.
[Laura] Not happy with the cakes.
It just looks really bumpy and uneven.
It's either start again or hold out.
I think I need to do them again.
[Matt] Just three hours
of the bake remain.
Oh, that goes so quickly.
That's one hour gone.
[Laura] Yeah, they're not right.
No. They're really not right.
Gonna stick to what I know.
Equal quantities of everything.
Who would you most be upset
if someone went?
-Ooh. I ain't saying.
-Got a few?
You always say that.
Not saying.
We're really good people in here.
This'll come out much later,
and by then, you won't care.
[both laugh]
-Would you like to get rid of Paul?
-Yeah, Paul.
[Laura] This batch
really does need to behave
because otherwise I'm definitely screwed.
[Matt] As Laura plays catch-up,
it's a critical point
in the bake for the others.
I know by the colour that's not ready,
so I'll leave that a bit longer.
[Matt] The high sugar content
in white chocolate
means the sponges will brown very quickly…
Five minutes.
[Matt] …which could deceive the bakers
into thinking they're baked through.
They're a lovely colour.
They need just maybe a minute or two.
[groaning] Oh, I don't know.
I'll put them in for another two minutes.
I listen to my cakes
to hear how bubbly they are.
If they're very bubbly
then there's a lot of liquid left in them.
You don't want a wet cake.
That's definitely ready.
Yeah, I think they're coming out.
[Mark] Really happy with them.
They look great.
Yeah, nice and golden.
I'm trying to play catch-up,
but I've got my cakes in the oven,
so fingers crossed.
Hi, David.
-Good morning.
-[Prue] David, tell us about your cake.
[Dave] So today, my cake's called
a strawberry-splash
white-chocolate Fraisier cake.
Oh, Fraisier cake, nice.
Putting the strawberries on the outside?
Outside, and a white-chocolate
crème mousseline in the middle.
It's gonna be decorated on top
with tempered-white-chocolate splashes.
[Matt] Dave's splashes will sit
on top of his amaretto-soaked sponges.
This is a cake he loves to bake
for his girlfriend Stacey's birthday,
and no birthday
is complete without balloons.
What's happening here
with these little guys?
There's one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
-I can count.
-There's…
Yeah. One for each baker.
-What are they gonna be?
-Chocolate splashes.
-Splashes?
-Mmm.
-Doing one for everyone.
-Yeah.
Aw. That's so sweet.
-And--
-And then you're gonna
burst them one by one
as you rise through the ranks.
-[mimics popping balloons]
-[both laugh]
Bakers, you are through way half.
-Is that right?
-Yeah.
[Lottie] Everyone's focused today,
there's no chat.
Not as much fun
as I thought it was gonna be.
No chat from Mark.
Everyone's taking it seriously,
like it's some competition.
You join us in the middle
of a very important bake.
It's all happening.
Laura is checking the temperature
of her sponges.
Laura, what do we think?
Right, these two are done.
Talk into the microphone, please.
[chuckles]
-Oh, sorry. Erm, these two are done.
-Excellent.
[Laura] I think the others just need…
-Actually, those are not done.
-These two are not done.
-False alarm, everybody.
-News flash.
-Breaking news, they are not done.
-Couple more minutes.
We will… We will come back to you later.
In the meantime, we'll go to the weather.
The thermometer's saying it's 25 degrees.
Not ideal for white chocolate.
[Noel] And not ideal conditions
for stacking layers of sponge
with delicate creamy fillings.
[Peter] This is feeling
a bit warm at the moment,
so I'm gonna have to work
as quick as I can.
Have to go like the clappers.
[Dave] The assembly
shouldn't take too long.
It's the chilling part that I need
the most amount of time on,
to firm up the mousseline.
-[Matt] As the layers build…
-So hot.
[Matt] …the bakers will need
to make full use of the fridges
to stop them melting and sinking
in the ever-warming tent.
[Laura] Glad I remade them.
They're looking good.
Much better. Yeah, panic averted.
Hot.
-[in sultry voice] Bakers…
-[laughs]
-…you have one hour left.
-[whistles]
That's not long.
[Noel] If dealing with white chocolate
in their sponges wasn't hard enough,
the bakers also need to temper it
to make their decorative elements.
[Dave] Just hoping they don't pop.
Now I'm making my white-chocolate collar.
I'll spread it out on the acetate
and then put it round the cake.
[Mark] This is the messy bit.
[Linda] This is just a lacey sort of
collar thing that I'm putting
round the outside of it.
Partially sets on the acetate
then it's easier to pick up
and lift onto and around the cake.
[Dave groans]
[Laura sighs] It's a mess isn't it?
[Sura] Too hot.
Literally melting in my hands.
Too, too hot.
I'm just gonna do some
chocolate drips down the side.
That's all I can do now.
[Australian accent]
You got ten minutes left.
-Don't mess it up.
-[blows raspberry]
It's pretty satisfying.
Ah, it's not coming off.
I may not get the rose done
but I'm hoping to.
I'm gonna just smooth this off.
[Australian accent]
Guys, nine minutes left.
You need to start making your cakes
round about now.
[laughs]
[Lottie] Do speed up, Lottie.
[Mark] I wanted much longer
to be able to do this.
[Dave] Looks good, don't it?
[Sura] It's just not working.
[Peter] I am painting on some
maths symbols and equations
and all that kind of jazz.
[Marc] I'm making roses.
This is my rose. Gonna do her proud.
That is not gonna stay.
Just gotta finish the ruffles.
I'd actually really love to make
something Paul liked today.
-[Sura] Rough and ready, innit?
-[Marc] The rose looks amazing.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
[Sura grunts]
[Marc] Ooh, that's scary canary.
[Dave] I'm really happy, yeah.
It couldn't have gone better
for me, I don't think.
They're breaking.
Going for the less is more.
[Lottie] Less is not more.
Have you seen mine?
[Sura] Whatever, I'm done.
-[Marc] Okay.
-I'm done.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please step away from your bakes.
[Mark] Looks awesome, Lottie.
It looks okay, it looks fine.
But I'm not happy with "okay" and "fine."
[Noel] Nine white-chocolate
celebration cakes
now face the judgement of Paul and Prue.
I love the way it looks.
-Thank you.
-[Prue] It looks original.
-It looks modern. I'd buy that.
-[Mark] Thank you.
It's a great-looking cake.
Naked element of it looks nice,
it's neat and I love
the drips are all equal.
And so I've got white-chocolate cake
with pistachio and lemon genoise
and then a white-chocolate sponge
with a marula fruit liqueur
and white-chocolate
Italian-meringue buttercream.
All the flavours are there
but they're quite delicate.
-Okay.
-It needs more of a hero flavour.
I don't think pistachio's
gonna be strong enough.
[Prue] It's a beautifully made cake.
-The flavour just needs a bit more oomph.
-Bit more oomph. Okay.
I love that. It's very cool.
I like what you've done with the sapphire.
I think it's imaginative,
I think it's exciting.
-It's beautiful, well done.
-Thank you.
It is three white-chocolate sponges
with a passionfruit curd
and a lime kind of syrup.
The flavour's good, textures aren't there.
It's overbaked.
-Mmm-hmm.
-So it is bone dry inside.
Yeah.
I actually think the work
on the chocolate looks fine.
My issue is…
-[Sura] It's leaning.
-The shape.
I mean,
-they're all over the place.
-They are.
[Prue] Hmm.
[Paul] You have raw dough.
[Prue] Looks like marzipan.
Your recipe was at fault
or you've weighed something up wrong.
Could've been the white chocolate
with the water.
Yeah, maybe.
Such a pity. It's not edible.
[sighs]
-It looks wonderful.
-Thank you.
The colour of the sponge worries me.
-It's very dark.
-Okay.
[Paul] Let's have a look inside.
Well, I don't think it's overbaked.
It does taste really good.
-Strawberries work well with it.
-Thank you.
I don't like the colour of the sponge,
but it's a decent cake.
-Thank you. Cool, thank you.
-I love it.
I really like it. Buttery,
white chocolate, bit of zest in there.
My issue is the decoration.
The piping work is not good.
-Oh.
-[Paul] At any level.
I think Paul is right.
It's a really delicious cake,
a little dense, piping not perfect.
-No.
-[Prue] But thank you.
-[Prue] It's neat.
-[Paul] It's a great-looking cake.
Very pastel.
-Yeah.
-[Paul] Let's have a look, shall we?
-Sponge is a little dense.
-Okay.
-It's weighed heavy on that.
-Yeah.
But I like the flavour
and the raspberry through it.
I think you've done a good job.
-And it tastes of white chocolate.
-Good.
-Well done, thank you.
-Thank you.
[Paul] The collar is beautiful and smooth.
And all the way round,
it just looks really neat.
It's a coconut cake
with mango-curd cream in the centre.
Oh, that'll be a chocolate chunk.
It's like toffee,
it's gluing my teeth together.
I think it's well baked.
Coconut flavour really comes through.
Mango lightens it up.
You've come up with something
that is very neat.
-Clever. Well done. Thank you.
-Thanks.
It's a little bit messy
down at the bottom.
Top bit's cute, quite like that.
-Just don't seem to go together.
-They don't.
It's like two different cakes.
-Mmm, delicious. Delicious.
-[Matt chuckles]
So, we call it a "Prue-gasm."
-[all laugh]
-[Matt moans]
[Paul] The lemon works beautifully
with the sponge.
It's got that citrus kick you want.
Well done, Hermine, it's just delicious.
Thank you very much.
Sometimes less is more…
that's sort of let it down a little bit.
Okay.
[Peter] Ooh.
Blackcurrant is beautiful.
I can't really get the white chocolate,
but since there's so much
white chocolate everywhere else,
perhaps that doesn't matter.
[Paul] Your sponges
are dried out slightly.
-You slightly overbaked it.
-Okay.
-But I love the blackcurrant.
-Thank you.
Works beautifully
with the white chocolate.
You put a lot of thought into it.
-Well, well done, Laura.
-Thank you.
[Laura] I'm a tiny bit disappointed,
'cause I really wanted to
nail it this week.
[sighs]
But the comment I really loved
was when Paul said
that a lot of thought had gone into it.
That meant a lot to me.
Yeah. I had a Prue roar.
It's a thing apparently now.
She goes… [grunts]
[laughs]
It went horrific.
Can't believe the cake was
like, pretty much raw inside.
I honestly don't know what to say.
So, kids, that was a tough week.
But we should talk first
about who could be Star Baker.
I think Peter, again, Mr Consistent.
Very clever, very neat,
the colour was good.
I liked the mango, as well.
[Prue] Can I talk about Mark L,
because I think his cake
was just beautiful.
He's been up there constantly, Mark L.
He was third in technical,
did well in signature
and he's done pretty good today.
So I think I would put
one of those two in line for Star Baker.
Who's in trouble?
Sura, I think.
Based on her showstopper being raw,
she made a big mistake with that.
-And probably Lottie.
-She was bottom in the technical.
Didn't do fantastically in the signature.
She did well in the showstopper
but has she done enough
to stay in the competition
and did Sura really fail that much
that she has to go?
I really like Lottie and Sura,
so I will go instead of them if you want.
-I'd be happy.
-Yes, we'll have that.
-See you, mate.
-[Noel laughs] Prue!
Thought I was your favourite.
See how easily they forget
once the new kid's in town.
The novelty of me will wear off.
I wouldn't get rid of him.
[laughs]
[Noel] Hello, bakers.
I've got the great job
of announcing Star Baker.
So the Star Baker is…
-Mark L.
-Oh, thank you.
-Ooh.
-[all clapping]
-Thank you, thanks.
-Smashed it.
[Hermine] Well done.
So it's up to me to announce
who is going home
and it is someone
who we're all really fond of,
but who had a bad week.
And so the baker who will be leaving us
this week is…
Sura.
-I was expecting that.
-[kisses]
You are honestly amazing. You're so good.
[Paul] Never mind. You're a good baker.
I'm gutted, but what's done is done.
I'm not gonna be bitter about it.
I've had a great time.
-[Prue sniffling] Sorry.
-[Sura] That's okay.
[Prue] You just had a bad week.
I hate white chocolate.
I hate chocolate, end of.
I don't think
I'll eat chocolate ever again.
[chuckles]
[Paul] I'm really sad to see Sura go.
Now that's a classic case of
you cannot have a weakness in your baking.
And unfortunately,
we found Sura's this week,
and it was that
that actually saved Lottie.
[Hermine laughing]
-[Paul] Just big it up for the next one.
-I'll try my best.
[sighs]
[Lottie] The sadness
that I feel at losing Sura
is at least partway made up
by Mark getting Star Baker.
That… I'll take that.
That will cheer me up.
-Well done, mate.
-[Mark] Thank you. Quite emotional.
-Are you?
-[Mark] Yeah.
-You're hiding it well. No.
-Am I?
[laughs] How did that happen?
Can't believe it.
Yeah. I just didn't expect it.
I think consistency pays off, doesn't it?
Thank you very much.
-[Paul] Well done. Really good.
-Surprised.
I'm delighted
that we're going down to the final
seven bakers, you know, like…
Seven, eight?
Eight. Is it eight?
Eight bakers. [laughs]
[closing theme music playing]